classmates at the kidnap Nigerian school
girls of told Sky News how they escaped
as authorities say they think the girls
are being held in a vast and remote
forest in the country's northeast well
let's stay with that story about the
kidnapped schoolgirls in Nigeria the
hashtag bringbackourgirls has appeared
all over the Twittersphere with Michelle
Obama and Malala yousufzai taking part
in the campaign to raise awareness but
can such actions however hard-hitting
really make a difference while joining
me it's Deborah Owen founder of made
equal which campaigns for women's rights
around the world Deborah what difference
do you think this campaign has made it's
brought out a new generation of
campaigners of people who are often able
to tweet and put out a message online
but it's actually began to bring people
to the street is brought about a level
and level of unity for people who are
around the world it doesn't matter where
you are if you're interested and you
want to be committed to this hashtag and
so seeing the young girls who've been
kidnapped coming home you're going to
put out a message that says bring back
our girls but sending out this message
and get involved in the protest and the
demonstrations and tweeting however
laudable it is and however laudable it
aim at it is there's other people who
say that's actually going to make no
difference on the ground whatsoever the
u.s. in the UK had committed to sending
military help there before there was the
big hashtag campaign a lot of people say
Boko Haram
they're not interested in what the West
things that are interested in a social
media campaign well ultimately it's
about how you bring around unity how you
raise awareness of an issue and the big
issue you know that we're seeing is
around sexual violence in conflict
around access to education for girls and
if that voice has been raised through
this campaign then it's it's successful
in some terms because we can see you
know organizations we can see
celebrities we can see politicians we
can see members of everyday society
coming out to say yes we stand against
this and we are going to use this
campaign to bring around awareness to
the issues what about those who argue
that that in a lot of of African
countries there is great concern about
Western intervention and the fact that
campaigns like this perhaps put pressure
on the u.s. to send in the military it
can actually be counterproductive
because you're sending in foreign troops
into areas where they don't want foreign
troops and they're actually fighting to
stop foreign troops
for example Boko Haram or was he
concerned about the westernization of
Nigeria I think what happens is you
begin to put pressure on those cut
governments there's a lot of issues
around corruption within Africa and so
if you're putting on outside pressure
from the West it means that governments
need to pull within Africa will pool
their their socks up they will begin to
hold tight the issues at hand and look
at how they're going to be able to deal
with those issues ultimately of all the
people who've tweeted who do you feel
has been the most useful is it Michelle
Obama or is it a celebrity I do think
Michelle Obama has been very
instrumental in this because not only is
she a mother but she is the president
and the president she is the first lady
of the United States of America and to
have such a public statement put out
there by somebody of such seniority such
so high up is amazing for the campaign
it's amazing for people who didn't even
know anything about it who didn't know
what was going on to have that message
coming out from the mother and you know
it's Mother's Day weekend at the moment
in the United States so mothers around
the world and other women can identify
with Michelle Obama can identify with
being a mother mother and I think she's
brought that out in this campaign what
about the critics who say that the
campaign's like this actually give these
groups that are quite smaller in some
sense isn't quite disparate the oxygen
of publicity and and make them a lot
bigger than they actually are in the
first place I think that Boko Haram has
been around for quite a while now and so
I don't think this incident particularly
is gonna make it bigger I think what it
is gonna do is allow individuals who may
be considering being part of any type of
negative group in society to reconsider
what the consequences of that will be it
won't just be the consequences of that
government it will be the consequences
of the world that will begin to look in
and want to take action against them
Deborah Owen from made equal thank you
very much thank you